Hey traders, it's Mike here and in this
video I'm going to explain why positive
delta can still be bearish. You know, we
had the high of the day right here.
Big strong positive delta of 1,001.
But the market sold off about 40 points
in about 5 minutes. And just because
buyers are aggressive doesn't mean that
they are winning. All right, so
you know, one of the biggest traps in
footprint trading
basically is when traders see strong
positive delta, they assume buyers are
in control. And then what happens and
like in this case where the the market
just reverses almost instantly. Now, all
positive delta means, right? All that
this 1,001 means is that buyers were
aggressive. It doesn't necessarily mean
that they were successful. And as a
trader you got to be asking yourself,
"Hey, I've got this strong positive
delta.
Are these aggressive buyers are they
successful? Are they getting paid?"
If not, what you're going to see is when
the market comes into resistance, you
know, and this was our high of the day.
Right? We're breaking out into the high
beyond the high of the day. Right? And
you have that aggressive buying, right?
You mean at one point the max delta was
1372.
But what happened is
it ran into what? It ran into resting
liquidity up in here at these new highs
that was absorbing all that aggressive
trading. Right? So, when you're coming
into a resistance level, positive delta,
especially a strong positive delta, can
show trapped traders. And what you want
to be looking for one is there
continuation?
No, we don't have any continuation. This
bar didn't wasn't green, it ended up
being red and it actually reversed
within the bar. At one point, again,
this was a nice big strong green candle
up with big positive delta because of
the strong aggressive buying, but that
aggressive buying basically dried up.
They they the aggressive buyers were
basically running out of of money to buy
more, right? They they can't buy
anymore. And once you remove that
aggressive buying from the market, what
you see is exactly what happened where
the market just starts actually selling
off because all that aggressive buying
has been satisfied.
Okay, so what you got to watch is again,
you know, watch when you're breaking out
past a resistance level, right? Look for
that aggressive buying and ask yourself,
"Are those aggressive buyers getting
paid?" If not, chances are high for a
nice reversal. Okay? So,
positive delta at a high with no
continuation
is a sign
of a reversal. So, just keep that in
mind when you're trading near highs and
then you just see it
not being followed through, you don't
have that aggressive buying. And again,
you know, maybe you're not convinced in
the candle itself. You're like, "Well,
you know what? I'm going to wait and
see." The next bar came in and look at
the next bar, negative delta of 391
right here, this red candle minus 391.
If still maybe you're not convinced, you
know, but by this point you should be.
Next candle comes in.
Big red candle down.
Five selling imbalances and even bigger
negative delta one minus 1070. But at
this point, you know, all you're able to
get out of this move is maybe about 20
points. Okay? But recognizing it early
at the reversal is key to
finding good trade location. If you're
getting short here,
where's your stop? It's just right up in
here. So, you know that if we come back
and we take off this high at 140, you're
wrong. Okay? But if you're getting short
at 125, that's a 15-point stop. Okay?
But you see from the 15 points 15 here,
it sold off from 125 down below
095. This is 30 points.
All right, so I hope you're able to
learn something from this video. Thanks
and I'll see you guys on the next one.